welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
voss and moonlight episode 4 just gave
this series it's gator loki meets pietro
at the door wtf twist as plowing through
the doors of mark and steven's
underworld mental hospital was
hello oh man it's just some random guy
no i am sorry to blaspheme the egyptian
goddess of fertility but that sweet
hello and hippo ear wiggle from
towerette just made my heart melt and
i'm sure all of you are now wondering do
what this hippo lady is all about so in
this video i'm gonna explain who tauret
is and what her appearance here tells us
about what is going on in this episode
four final scene as well as the wider
nature of spirituality in the mcu now
the best way to support us here at new
rockstars is to get our moon knight
inspired to the moon god shirt at new
rockstarsmerch.com we are almost sold
out of these so you gotta move fast so
tarauret or tawaret there are probably
multiple ways to pronounce this and they
are all wrong she is the egyptian
goddess of fertility childbirth and in
general protection her name translates
to the great one and she takes the form
of a hippopotamus the hippopotamus
considered one of the fiercest creatures
in all of africa she is voiced here by
the actress antonia saleeb and she's
credited for not just this episode but
also episodes five and six but this
actually is not tawara it's first
appearance in moon night she got a shout
out in the very first episode when donna
and steven did inventory at the museum
bring those hippos up here will you yeah
sure
power wet it
the hippo got his tail with it now
episode four's ending seems to reframe
all the events of this series as
delusions possibly within mark or
steven's mind with donna herself
clutching one of these plush toys that
of the scarab but i actually think it's
the other way around the underworld
realm that mark and steven now occupy is
being populated with projections of
people and imagery from their waking
lives more on that in a bit but perhaps
the more critical towards sighting has
come in every episode during the credit
sequence one shot has shown a lineup of
all the other ushavi stone figurines one
of them on the back right is clearly
tuaret she has been watching us since
the beginning protecting us wiggling
those ears the whole time now these
ushabtes appeared beside the entrance of
the iniads temple inside the great
pyramid of giza and in wall cubby holes
in the opening shot of episode 4
suggesting that the five members of the
inead have banished countless other
deities before they did this takanchu
and ahmet and one of those deities was
touaret now our friends at epic hero
shop have some of the coolest shirts in
merch they have a new spider-man no way
home shirt with the lovable face of
peter j parker and a who the hell is
this phrase i mean our brains were wiped
who is this handsome devil they have
also just released the latest in their
tales from the multiverse series with a
memorable boy wizard taking on the
sorcerer's supreme mantle
so put your order in as soon as possible
so you can wear it opening night another
very cool shirt to wear to the theater
would be the wanda variant of the
unusual couple shirt it's an augmented
reality shirt so your friends in line
for popcorn can use their phones to
unlock a video layer on that shirt and
you better believe they released a
strongest avenger trucker hat about 10
seconds after the thor 11 thunder
trailer dropped so get yourself one of
these or any of their marvel star wars
and dc inspired gear at epicheroshop.com
they've got more moon night shirts than
konchu has avatars sign up for their
newsletter at the bottom of their
website to get notified about the merch
drops be your own hero now my
interpretation of the episode 4 ending
is that this is mark and steven's
perspective of the mcu underworld called
the duot in egyptian mythology which
stephen explained back in the first
episode they believed you needed your
heart to be judged in the underworld and
only the worthiest would be allowed to
pass through the field of reads did it
suck for you getting rejected from the
field of reads well that don't make
sense cause i'm not dead am i stevie
so i think either literally or
metaphorically this whole series has
been that voyage through the field of
reads episode one showed mark passing a
thick tangle of brooms on the sidewalk
outside his door a detail that seemed
very random at the time but now i think
might have represented those reads in
that episode amit was unable to judge
stephen maybe because steven wasn't
ready to be judged that comes at the end
of the voyage episode 2 showed him
running along the river thames episode 3
showed him and layla on a boat cruising
along the river nile and now finally in
episode 4 he sinks into the depths like
that sunken boat we have seen at the
bottom of gus's fish tank and we know
from promo footage that at some point
this season we will see an egyptian boat
in some purple tinted landscape paddling
through waves of sand and since the
iniad lives in the overvoid i think that
the mental hospital represents the
underworld mark as a d.i.d patient
linked with an egyptian moon deity
manifests this afterlife plane the way
other mcu characters with godly powers
see their afterlives t'challa imbued
with the power of bost sees it as the
ancestral plane a savannah that's
populated with his ancestors as panthers
thanos imbued with the cosmic power of
all six infinity stones saw it as the
zeobrae gate where he first met his
daughter gamora all of this represents a
spiritual plane where souls in the mcu
elevated to the godly tear go to a place
where their inner desires manifest the
appearance of that reality for mark and
stephen it's a mental hospital based on
the pamphlet back in episode 2 a place
where they just want to get help yet
still their inner self-doubt casts the
staff of that hospital as their greatest
enemies and inside of this realm they
are united with all the other deities
the inead has turned into ushaptis
konchu amit and tawaret tawara in
addition to being the goddess of
fertility is also a source of
rejuvenation guiding souls through the
duats she could be a helpful companion
for mark during this transition toward
either passage or resurrection one deity
to be a friend of this guy when every
other deity really wants to exploit him
but why would the indiana banish sawarat
a sweetheart doula just protecting all
mothers and babies and if she's just one
of many statues why is this character
such a focal character coming back in
episodes five and six well i think we
can all agree after episode three showed
that the indiana's approach to justice
is complete [ __ ] they side with
arthur harrow's ad hominem attacks on
mark's mental health refusing to look at
harrow's crimes in progress just because
one witness was a little unreliable
there was that whole moment with osiris
and harrow at the end of episode 3 where
someone's clearly lying in the other's
pockets so i think this corruption plus
the missing members of the imiad and
hawthorne horus not even supposed to be
on this panel but just randomly promoted
to it plus all these other randomly
banished gods all of this is intentional
evidence that the iniad is corrupt and
very much on a power trip looking for
every excuse to lock up the deities that
just are not in alignment with their
views so tawarits represents fertility
in childbirth concepts that don't
necessarily apply to mark and steven
that much since their story seems more
about death and reality and control also
you know their their plumbing is
different but the fact that tuaret was
banished could mean the ine ad
overreacted to something else to where
it was up to something with major
implications for other concurrent events
in the mcu now we know from the grc
easter egg in episode 2 that moon knight
takes place in the post-blip mcu world
when the population suddenly increased
as the 50 of the life that dusted
suddenly returned this is something that
every marvel disney plus series keeps
touching on the chaos when monica
returned in the hospital in one division
the strain on earth's resources
necessitating the grc's existence in the
falcon the winter soldier the population
toll on the environment culminating in
the destruction of haven hills alabama
in 2050 seen in loki and elena's return
in hawkeye and in eternals a movie that
opened with another sighting of the grc
billboard also in london we learned that
this population increase was the trigger
that finally awakened tiamut which
nearly resulted in the complete
destruction of this planet now the
indiana made it clear that they do not
interfere with human affairs a sharp
contrast with the godly protectors like
the eternals whom the inead must have
crossed paths with at some point or at
least knew they existed as we saw among
makari's collection several egyptian
artifacts so if taware is the goddess of
childbirth the indiana might have
cruelly punished her for in their
[ __ ] logic overdoing things when it
comes to human reproduction on this
planet like unwittingly nursing a
sleeping celestial banishing tawaret
could have been their form of population
control and now a side effect of this
banishment may be seen in doctor strange
in the multiverse of madness which is a
story about motherhood wanda is unable
to find her children throughout the
multiverse and just wants to live in a
reality where she can be a mother now i
don't know if moon knight or multiverse
of madness will make this link explicit
like i don't know if doctor strange 2
has room for hippo goddesses in it but
wanda's struggle is occurring in the
context of a reality where the goddess
assigned to protect mothers has been
banished to the underworld now i guess
how aligned those stars are really
depends on who you pray to follow me on
instagram and twitter at eavos follow me
rockstar subscribe to rockstar somewhere
announces of everything you love thanks
for watching to our red
[Music]
you